hey everyone thanks for joining us yet
again for another video this time we're
here to thank you thank you so much for
being part of our journey to one million
subscribers we are truly grateful and
humbled that you've allowed us to be
part of your developer journey and to
thank you for that we'd love to take a
look at some of the amazing things that
have happened over the past few years so
sit back and enjoy the road to 1 million
[Music]
for me the road to 1 million really
started when Rado and I moved from
Android developer relations over to
Cloud developer relations well Technic
technician youth follow along later sure
fine if you want to split hairs when we
joined back in what 2018 the channel was
just getting off the ground and we were
tasked with building it into something
great it was already a solid foundation
some good content was coming out but
there was an opportunity to do a lot
more and build it into a stronger
resource for developers but besides that
we really didn't have a lot to go on and
so a lot of the projects early on were
just trying to figure out what the
audience would respond to I mean Rado
was bringing in lab coats for the
bigquery series we were doing screencast
trying all sorts of mediums for
different products just to see what
would happen with it and as long as it
was Scrappy as long as we moved fast and
as long as it was under budget like
really low budget didn't you build a
studio in your house for like 300 bucks
uh yeah we we didn't have the budget to
get me a remote studio so I ended up
rebuilding one in my house by hand
complete DIY style I mean I I built a
teleprompter out of wood in an old
picture frame I hung rigging for lights
out of old trekking poles I had I hung
the green screen and a closet so that I
could get the right lighting when all
the dust had settled I think we filmed
like 70 videos with that setup I think
build out was the project that showed us
there was a lot of untapped potential to
be had the production there was higher
than we'd done in the past and the
engagement we got from it I think was
the thing that convinced more developer
Advocates to start making video content
I wanted to find a new way to introduce
and tell stories around machine learning
and AI then all of a sudden our YouTube
channel really just started taking off
seemed like the right fit you think's
video series was super ambitious he
wanted to talk about a new topic but had
a really aggressive Cadence from the
production side we wanted to see if we
could start growing our audience
internationally we started optimizing
the content so that more viewers could
find it and see it I think it worked it
was bizarre one morning I woke up and
had hundreds of new LinkedIn requests
and email contacts when I got to the
office a co-worker sent me a screenshot
my latest YouTube video had reached 1
million views once that happened a lot
of people took notice suddenly everybody
wanted video content it was time to
build a team it was time to build a team
I was so excited to join this new team
of cloud content creators but looking
back I had no idea all the cool things
that I was going to get to work on or
just how big this whole thing was going
to get or that there'd be this much
content early on we were filming 10 or
12 episodes in a four hour block it was
intense
it really wasn't that bad well I kind of
knew what I was getting into but I kept
that to myself it's best to let others
find out in their own time I think the
data center video was the big
breakthrough moment for me like I never
thought that I would ever work on
something like that let alone step foot
inside a Data Center and do it at that
high quality with that kind of reception
it was so amazing and humbling all at
once I remember the first time I walked
into the get cooking in Cloud Studio it
absolutely blew my mind the team had
done such an amazing job setting up all
the utensils the backsplash and all of
that it was absolutely amazing I don't
even cook and I enjoyed being in that
space anytime you need to buy kitchen
equipment I'm in my favorite episodes
were our Snack Chat Series where we
ranked all the different foods in the
Google micro kitchens although my
stomach was not too happy about it that
night
welcome to
[Music]
dude
yeah I think we were a little ahead of
our time on that
but not just build a team build a sense
of purpose a great group of people were
working collaboratively was part of our
core values this team has really been a
family for me I mean the content we make
is one thing but the people
they are phenomenal I'm here for the
tech but just as much for the team I
learned from them every single day on
every single project we work on together
they're all such great blog writers
script writers developers and truly fun
people
the biggest challenge we had was working
from home we suddenly had this group of
people who couldn't do their jobs
without Studio access so we had a
scramble really really fast we got film
kits out to everyone as soon as we could
[Music]
we had our team find spare spaces in
their houses it didn't matter if it was
their kitchen their closet whatever they
could find
[Music]
so that meant we had to train our
developer Advocates to use the gear
suddenly they became the production crew
I feel like I know everything about Film
Production now Hollywood get ready I
thought it was amazing when we set up
the lightboard studio in my house but
now it's just taking up space I mean in
some ways it's less stressful because
you're in your home but in other ways
it's a lot more work because you're
setting up and running the equipment
yourself and the mic picks up the noise
of every delivery truck within a block
it's kind of poetic if you think about
it when this started Colt was doing most
of the filming out of his home in a
spare bedroom now a million subscribers
later everyone else has had a chance to
do the same thing I mean not my
intention but I'm happy to take credit
for it although I gotta say I'm pretty
sure most everyone is still wearing
pajamas in those videos
here at Google Cloud
or letting
a part of your developer Journey and
from everyone on our team here we can't
wait to see what you build next
[Music]